this is every country in the world by
Wendover productions
we'll start with Afghanistan the first
country alphabetically Afghanistan is
one of the few countries worldwide to be
offset from Greenwich Mean Time by a
30-minute interval it's at GMT plus four
hours and 30 minutes while China is one
of the many countries to only have one
timezone except it's ginormous so that
means that stepping over the 47
mile-long Afghanistan China border jumps
you forward by three and a half hours
that's the largest single time zone jump
on earth China in all its craziness has
a rather ambitious plan to build a
high-speed rail road from Beijing up
across the Bering Strait and down into
the United States which happens to be
the home of forty one percent of one of
our productions viewers up in the
northwest of the u.s. Point Roberts a
part of the mainland US is cut off from
the US by Canada and since it doesn't
have a high school students have to
cross into Canada then back into the
u.s. each day on their way to school
Canada happens to be the second largest
country on earth and has more legs than
the rest of the world combined it's so
huge in fact that its easternmost point
is closer to Croatia than it is to
Vancouver one of Croatia's thousands of
islands is wrapped the birthplace of the
sculptor marinas who went on and founded
San Marino the fifth smallest country in
the world in one of three to be
completely surrounded by another country
one of the others is the Vatican the
smallest sovereign state in the world
and there's also Lesotho which is home
to one of Africa's seven ski resorts
Lesotho is of course surrounded by South
Africa which is the only country in the
world to have three capitals Cape Town
is to see the Parliament Pretoria is
home to the president and Blum fontaine
is the judicial capital South Africa
also almost completely surrounds another
country Swaziland where roads are so bad
that two of the last four transport
ministers died in car accidents while
mostly surrounded by South Africa
Swaziland eastern border is with
Mozambique whose name scores higher in
Scrabble than any other one-word country
when in second place for Scrabble is
kyrgyzstan which is home to six enclaves
the smallest of which is part of is
becca stan and is only two miles wide a
news Becca Stan no River leads to the
ocean they all drain into endorheic
basins where water evaporates out Moo's
Becca San is one of only two countries
worldwide to be double landlocked as in
landlocked by landlocked countries in
this case every surrounding country of
Uzbekistan
also ends in Stan Kazakhstan Tajikistan
Kyrgyzstan Afghanistan and Turkmenistan
the other double landlocked country is
listen Stein a tiny and historically
neutral nation in their last military
engagement in 1886 none of the 80
soldiers were injured or killed and they
actually returned with 81 people since
they made a quote new Italian friend
Italy is home to the bruiser vineya ski
resort where you can ski across the
border into Switzerland Switzerland is
rather paranoid about war to the extent
that 3,000 points of entry into the
country are rigged to blow at an instant
in case of invasion Switzerland is also
home to one end of the shortest
regularly scheduled commercial
international flight in the world a
six-minute 10 mile jaunt over to Germany
where it's not actually illegal to
escape prison seriously they say it's
only human nature Germany is home to
half of one of the world's few
internationally divided Islands and the
Polish side of this island despite being
only 200 feet from mainland Poland is
not connected by any bridges to Poland
so just like Point Roberts residents
have to cross international border to
get to their own country Poland also
happens to have been part of Sweden's
monarchy for a brief eight years in the
16th century Sweden has an
internationally divided Island - and
this one is a mere seven acres large the
border looks like this because Finland
accidentally built a lighthouse in
Swedish territory and so they just
readjusted the border to make everyone
happy Finland has exactly 180 7888 Lakes
and its northernmost point is actually
closer to Greenland and Poland due to
the curvature of the earth
Greenland isn't actually a country so
I'm not allowed to talk about it it's a
dependency of Denmark where it's
impossible to be more than 30 miles from
the ocean the wife of Denmark's crown
prince Crown Princess Mary was born in
Australia which is the sixth largest
country on earth and is home to the
longest fence in the world a 3,500 mile
structure to keep wild dogs out of the
Fertile Southeast region the middle of
Australia also has practically nobody
and nothing in it except a 297 mile long
precisely straight section of railroad
track Australia freed the country Brunei
from occupation back in World War two
which is one of the few countries
worldwide to be comprised of two
comparable sized sections st. Kitts and
Nevis is also
but that's because it's a to island
nation and also the smallest country in
the Americas in st. kitts and nevis you
can gain citizenship by making a four
hundred thousand dollar real estate
investment much like Bulgaria where
people not up and down to signify no and
shake left and right to meet yes
Bulgaria is one of the few countries to
have an embassy in North Korea which
created its own time zone in 2015 for no
real reason than to be different North
Korea is only separated by one country
from Norway where more than half the
population lives below this line between
Norway and North Korea is of course
Russia the largest country in the world
its easternmost point is in fact closer
to Mexico than Moscow Mexico once had
three different presidents in one hour
during a military coup but also
accustomed to short regimes is alles s
Lorraine in France which was a fully
recognized independent country for 12
short days between being a part of
Germany and France at the end of World
War 1 France of course had an enormous
empire including Algeria which is the
largest country in Africa and unlike
some of its bordering countries is quite
nice to women 70% of the country's
lawyers are female right next door to
Algeria is Morocco which has de facto
control of some of Western Sahara
a place that's really not part of any
country that's why it's always blank on
data maps Morocco surrounds two Spanish
exclaves say Utah and media which are
politically part of mainland Spain
rather than overseas territories despite
being in northern Africa Spain once had
an enormous Empire part of which was
Micronesia which is now a u.s.
associated state meaning that there are
an independent nation but the u.s.
covers defense and funding Micronesian
citizens can join the US military
without becoming a u.s. resident a right
only given to freely associated States
their currency is also the US dollar
Palau is also a nearby US associated
State which is often compared to Fiji
since they're both idyllic Pacific
island destinations even though there
are over 3,500 miles apart Fiji was a
British colony up until 1970 and you
have no idea how hard it was to avoid
using this transition up until now I
could have used it with naruse and kitts
and nevis Brunei Australia South Africa
Canada the United States and Afghanistan
but I kept it for now the UK is home to
the shortest regularly scheduled
commercial flight in the world between
Westray and Papa West right in the
Scottish Isles it cost 17 pounds takes
53 seconds and traverses only one
point seven miles the UK has two
exclaves both of which are overseas
territories one is to broader right
across from say Utah and the other is
Akrotiri and Dhekelia on the island of
Cyprus there are border control agents
from three countries on Cyprus the UK
Cyprus and Turkey Northern Cyprus is a
self-declared state only recognized by
Turkey who helps them keep control of
the territory with a heavy military
presence and border control agents
Istanbul Turkey is the only city on the
planet to span two continents Europe and
Asia although there are plenty of
countries on two continents in Egypt the
Sinai Peninsula sits in Asia while the
rest is in Africa just past the southern
border of Egypt is bir tawil a piece of
land claimed by no country since Egypt
and Sudan disagree on where their
borders are Sudan recently split into
two and created South Sudan the world's
youngest UN recognised country the
second youngest country is Serbia which
up until 2006 was called Serbia and
Montenegro
but split after a referendum Montenegro
also happens to be a town in Costa Rica
where about 100 people live the capital
of Costa Rica San Jose only allows car
owners to drive six days a week to fight
pollution and congestion so the last
digit of license plates correspond to
their banned day Costa Rica's southern
border is with Panama home to the Panama
Canal which counter-intuitively has its
Atlantic end the ocean to the east to
the west and it's specific end the ocean
to the west to the east
Panama's southern border is with
Colombia but there's not one road
crossing this 50-mile jungle which means
it's impossible to drive between North
and South America you probably know that
Colombia was once part of Spain but so
was the Netherlands it was called the
Spanish Netherlands the Netherlands is
also home to barley nests ow one of the
most messed up borders in the world
Belgium is well known for having a UN
headquarters and so does Nero B Kenya
the suspected birthplace of the human
race
Kenya's northern neighbor is Somalia
which received its first ATM machine in
2014 Somalia has had three separate wars
with Ethiopia in the last century and
Ethiopia's national airline was the
second to receive the 787 dreamliner
despite being the 13th poorest country
Ethiopia also has another one of those
internationally divided islands this one
with Djibouti which is home to the
lowest point in Africa
lekha Sal at 509 feet below sea level
Djibouti also hosts the only US military
base in Africa and Israel hosts one of
the smallest ones
Damona radar base despite being a Middle
Eastern country Israel competes in
Eurovision and many European sports
leagues since they're culturally much
closer to Europe than the Middle East
Israel has one of the weirder
international borders with Palestine
which is only a country depending on who
you ask the largest Palestinian
community outside the Arab world is in
Chile which is one of the only countries
to have a government-sponsored UFO
research organization Chile is the
southernmost mainland country in the
world but doesn't have the southern most
commercial airport that title goes to
Argentina with air Oshawott Malvinas
International Airport this spectacular
waterfall is the border between
Argentina and Brazil which is home to
the Amazon River which doesn't have a
single bridge over it not one it's just
in an area where practically nobody
lives
SCV Brazil is closer to Dakar Senegal
then to port a leg in southwestern
Brazil just off the coast of Senegal is
Cape Verde which is pretty much paradise
they have a high human development index
score high GDP high literacy rate and
the lowest recorded temperature in
history there was 50 degrees Fahrenheit
as a former Portuguese colony Cape Verde
speaks Portuguese which is the sixth
most spoken language in the world even
though its origin country Portugal is
smaller than Kentucky they just have an
enormous Empire which for a while
included Indonesia which has another one
of those internationally divided island
with Papua New Guinea similar to
Hispaniola Island which is divided
between Haiti and the Dominican Republic
Hispaniola is the 22nd largest island in
the world but Madagascar is number four
it's also the largest single island
country eighty-five million years ago
Madagascar was connected to India before
the continent shifted but Sri Lanka was
connected to India as recently as 1480
via a land bridge that is since eroded
Sri Lanka is just north of the equator
but right on the equator is Ecuador its
capital Quito is only 20 miles from the
equator so it's day length varies by
only 15 minutes between winter and
summer although since the country is
split by the equator winter and summer
happens at the same time in the same
country Ecuador is one of the 30
countries to have an Antarctic research
base and right next door to Ecuador's
Bay
is Peru's Copacabana not that one this
one in Bolivia can only be reached by
driving through Peru Bolivia despite
being a landlocked country maintains a
5,000 person Navy although Mongolia also
a landlocked country maintains a navy
that has one ship a tugboat and seven
total sailors Mongolia is also the least
dense country on the planet with only 5
people per square mile
while they may seem unintimidating now
the Mongolian Empire was once the
largest contiguous land Empire in
history part of that Empire was Cambodia
which has changed its name six times in
the last 65 years
95% of Cambodia's population is
Theravada Buddhists the other major
branch of Buddhism is Maya Hana Buddhism
which is practiced in Japan where out of
the total population of a hundred and
twenty-six million they had three gun
murders in 2012 Iceland however can top
that because they had one murder total
in 2012 of course Iceland doesn't have a
huge population which makes it seem less
impressive until you consider that 30
percent of Iceland's residents own guns
60 percent of that population however
lives in this circle Iceland was also
the first country to recognize armenia's
independence and Armenia separates
Azerbaijan from its ninth even exclave
and since the Armenia Azerbaijan border
is closed
residents of nights even have to go all
the way around Armenia to get to their
own country Azerbaijan's national soccer
team has played Andorra's five times in
the last few decades and four of those
games have ended in a 0-0 tie Andorra is
the largest country in the world to not
have an airport which is less impressive
when you consider that there the 19th
smallest in the world the smallest
country in the world to have a major
international airport is the Maldives
the eighth smallest country this airport
has dozens of destinations and is on a
small island with no land connections to
other islands
which means that once you land you have
to either take a boat or a seaplane to
your destination one of the airport's
destinations is Kuala Lumpur in Malaysia
which is home to the world's largest
roundabout in Putrajaya at 2 miles in
diameter Malaysia is the only country
connected by road to Singapore the
largest surviving city-state in the
world despite having hundreds of
skyscrapers Singapore is not the
dentist' country in the world that title
goes to Monaco which is less than one
square mile law
Monaco has no income tax much like the
Bahamas which is one of two countries to
have the word the in its official name
the other one being the Gambia the
Gambia interesting shape comes from the
flow of the river Gambia whose watershed
reaches all the way to Guinea which is
one of three countries to have the word
Guinea in its name the other two are
Guinea Bissau
in Equatorial Guinea Guinea was once the
word for the entire West African region
so when these countries became
independent from their colonizers many
chose to include Guinea in their names
Equatorial Guinea is capital actually
isn't on the mainland it's on an
offshore island and despite its name the
Equator doesn't actually intersect
Equatorial Guinea but the country is on
both sides of the Equator since they
have sovereignty over annobón island to
the south of the Equator this is similar
to Kiribati a nation comprising of a few
dozen islands in the Pacific Kiribati is
the first place on earth to experience
new years since their time zone is UTC
plus 14 a time zone exclusive to these
islands Kiribati is close friends with
Cuba since Cuba sent doctors to the
islands who reduced the child mortality
rate by 80 percent Cuba
the only Caribbean island to have a
commercial railroad is one of the few
remaining communist states one of the
others is Laos the only landlocked
country in Southeast Asia which borders
Vietnam also communist and the
fourteenth most populous country in the
world despite having the size of about
New Mexico Vietnam is good political
friends with Venezuela who is not great
friends with or during Guyana since
Guyana thanks to the border it looks
like this and Venezuela thinks the
border looks like this Guyana the only
english-speaking country in South
America borders Suriname a the smallest
country in South America and the only
country other than the Netherlands whose
sole primary language is Dutch Suriname
a was our 98th country so that means
that were half way through and that
that's the end of part 1 of every
country in the world however
part 2 will be out on Tuesday December
13th so make sure you're subscribed to
catch that right when it comes out if
you enjoyed this and other Wendover
productions videos please consider
supporting the channel on patreon every
dollar contributed over there goes right
into the channel and I even release
expense reports to show you where your
money went you can receive great rewards
through that like t-shirts stickers
early access to videos and more
you can either click here or go to WWE
ENCOM slash win over productions
please also follow me on Twitter at
whenever Pro watch my last video on the
five freedoms of aviation check out my
fan moderated subreddit at reddit comm /
r / 1 / productions and once more
subscribe to this channel I'll see you
next - today for part 2 of every country
in the world